do you know how great the situation is I
do understand children I've got children
and do you love those children Indigo
please from the death of her majesty the
queen is she at peace now
yes
and the war in Ukraine don't interrupt
me to the secret of living a long life
well I suppose it is really
um not to do anything boring what is it
they say break a leg yes well we try not
to oh okay we've spoken to those behind
the headlines the Iranian regime sustain
the way they are treating people is just
the way they arrest you and they
disconnect you from the rest of the
world Auschwitz
it's what happens if we do not stop evil
before when I was black I was gay I was
working because I was a refugee Sean
Paul thank you so much for coming in but
you can see from my smile how happy I am
to see you and I'm pleased to say the
man himself Brian Cox is with us now uh
you are live on Sky News please do not
sweat she can't say whether I'm good or
not I know I'm good
[Music]
oh gosh you're just like Cliff the queen
of Hollywood Showbiz royalty no less
Dame Joan Collins well thank you very
much for joining us
top secret documents home potentially
risking the security of the United
States yeah I think that it's something
that again this seems like it's an issue
of paperwork and you didn't say a word
about the reasons for the especially
military operation it's not a special
military operation it is a full-scale
illegal war I've been to Ukraine a few
times before and I kind of knew that
they were going to fight I tried to look
into her face I saw it was all in blood
she still tried to breathe I hope she
didn't understand she didn't feel the
pain we are providing support to Ukraine
to help them uphold the right for
self-defense against a brutal aggression
of Russia 2022 has been in a big year
for news get out from Ukraine Mr Putin
do you think he has any conscience or do
you think he is simply a monster
the second one